Speaker 1: It is being reported that Russian
President Vladimir Putin is readying nuclear
weapons. What does this mean? Can we trust it?
But maybe most importantly, what is it actually
like to theorize about what would happen if such
weapons were to be unleashed? So let's start with
the beginning. A number of not very good sources
and then some. Okay sources are reporting things
like what Newsweek is reporting. Russia Prime's
nuclear bomb, 12 times more powerful than that,
dropped on Hiroshima. Now let's break down
the headline, More Powerful than that dropped
on Hiroshima. This is a very common 21st century
headline. The it's very common that now the nukes
that countries have access to are more powerful
than the one that was dropped on Hiroshima. So
that doesn't tell us too, too much. But let's look
into the details. Video of an intercontinental
ballistic missile on a silo launcher has been
released by Russia's Defense Ministry and widely
reported by the country's media in an apparent
warning to the West. A Russian tabloid newspaper
reported that the yars missile complex, which
was loaded in the Kaluga region, had a capacity
12 times greater than the American bomb that
destroyed Hiroshima in 1945. The mass circulation
papers report outlined some of the missile
specifications, including a launch weight of
46,000 tons, which some are disputing as plausible
as implausible an operational range of up to
12,000 kilometers that can strike the U.S. or
anywhere in Europe and a payload of up to 500
kilo tons. Now, is Putin doing this and what
might cause him to do something like this?
We can't say with complete and total certainty.
So I think it's maybe more interesting and more
relevant to talk generally about what this would
be like, what would it look like geopolitically
and in terms of the science of it. If Russia
launched a nuke of roughly this size against
the West. Often we just say, well, it would be
a general nuclear winter nuclear holocaust. But
I find that it's better to be a little more
specific the exact outcomes of what would
happen if Russia were to launch one of these
nukes. Let's let's put it at one for the time
being as more likely that it would be one rather
than a bunch just for the sake of discussion. The
consequences would really depend on the specific
target and and the number of weapons used. But
the potential consequences would likely include
the destruction of whatever city is hit and the
infrastructure of that city. So you're talking
buildings, you're talking roads, bridges and
power grids already catastrophic. But those are
the primary impacts that we have to talk about,
the sort of like follow on effects. You then would
have contamination of large areas with radiation
that has significant consequences in terms of long
term health effects for the survivors, potentially
making the areas uninhabitable. And of course, the
impact that that would have on the ability to grow
food. Remember, the bridges are destroyed, the
roads are destroyed. So if you can't grow food,
where do you bring food from? If the bridges and
the and the roads are also destroyed? So you can
see how these are compounding effects, economic
disruption on a global scale. Trade and financial
markets would likely be devastated. A significant
geopolitical escalation would likely likely
happen. It's sort of an understatement. I think
the question is to what extent and how quickly
does the West respond in kind? Does this lead
to a full scale war involving nuclear weapons,
which these are these are just such dystopian
scenarios that it can be hard to think about them,
sort of in practical terms. And then, of
course, the general increase in likelihood
that other countries would use their own
nuclear weapons and and a global nuclear
conflict that could develop. Really important to
understand the catastrophic nature here. I mean,
think about just one item. Like to go back to food
supply. Nuclear bombing would have a catastrophic
effect on the food supply in the affected areas.
The explosion itself would destroy farmland,
crops, livestock, food stores that exist. So you
immediately have food shortages. The contamination
of the environment with radiation could make it
difficult or even impossible to grow crops, to
raise animals in those affected areas, furthering
the food shortages into long term. Then you've got
to bring food in from somewhere else. But the
infrastructure was destroyed, as I mentioned,
the roads, the bridges, the ports. So transporting
food in becomes difficult. Exacerbating those very
shortages. And so just to take one area food, the
use of a nuke could devastate the food supply and
leave lead to widespread starvation. So that's
just food that we're talking about. How long
would areas be affected by a nuke? The effects of
radiation on the environment can last for years,
and it can take a significant amount of time
before it would be safe to live in an affected
area, to to grow food in an effective area,
affected area, to raise animals. It can take a
very long time. And in some cases, effects can
be what for the human lifespan we would call
permanent or semi-permanent. So we don't know
what's going on with Putin right now. Health
questions, questions about his mental state,
questions about what is the game plan here
with what's going on in Ukraine. And we have
increasing but isolated and not exquisitely
well-sourced reports that nukes are being readied.
We have to hope, of course, it doesn't go in that
direction. And to the extent that diplomacy can
be used to prevent that, we should welcome it.